The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
HONG LIU: OK.
So last time, we talked
about this IR-UV connection
between the bulk
and the boundary.
So the key thing is-- let me
write down the metric here,
the Ads metric in this
Poincare coordinate.
So this is the boundaries
are equal to zero.
And when you increase
z, you go to interior.
And then for each
constant, z, you
have a Minkowski space time.
You have a Minkowski d.
So this is Ads d plus 1.
So each slice is a d
dimension Minkowski space.
And due to this redshift
factor, the more
you go to the interior
of the space time,
then corresponding
to the lower energy
process when viewed
form the field theory.
So here, the same
process is happening here
compared to happening here,
and here corresponding
to the IR process, and
the [INAUDIBLE] boundary
corresponding to the UV process.
So this is a key
relation between the bulk
and the boundary theories.
And also, this gives you
an intuitive understanding
where does this actual dimension
come from from the field theory
point of view.
Then from the field
theory perspective,
this actual dimension can be
considered as a geometrization
of the energy scale.
And we know that the physics
change with the energy scale
from the field
theory point of view.
It's called the
normalization group flow,
how physics evolves when you
change the energy or length
scale.
In the field theory, it's
called normalization group flow.
So you can also view that the
evolution in the gravity side,
say from the boundary
to the interior,
and that this flow
in the z direction
can be considered,
again, to geometrize
the normalization group
flow of the field theory.
So any questions regarding this?
Good.
So now let's talk about some
further aspects of the duality.
So the duality is
that once you realize
there's such relation, since
the two sides are completely
different objects, so the
game is that you really
have to do lots of guess work.
Essentially, you have
two sides if you want
to relate things on two sides.
And you have to do guess work.
How does this quantity translate
into that quantity, et cetera?
And then check the consistency.
Just like you don't
know two languages,
and then you have to guess
between the two languages
and then build up
the dictionary.
And we will be doing the same.
We will be doing the same.
Good.
So this is more like a review
of what we already sad.
So let me be more explicit.
We have N equals 4
super Yang-Mills theory.
And then here, you have type
IIB string in Ads5 times ds5.
So let me just write down
Ads5 just for simplicity.
So here on this side, there
is a conformal symmetry
which we explained
before because this
is a four dimensional theory.
So the conformal symmetry of a
d dimensional series SO d, 2.
And on this side,
there's precisely
the same group,
which is isometry
of Ads5, which is
precisely also SO 4,
2, which we reviewed before.
And you can write down the
transformation on both sides.
In your pset, you have
checked some of them,
that they actually one to
one correspond to each other.
For example, this special
conformal transformation.
And the others, like translation
or rotation, et cetera,
it's clear.
AUDIENCE: But being
the right hand side,
we still have some SO 5, S5.
HONG LIU: I will
talk about that.
So this is more like
a space time symmetry.
So this is a space
time symmetry.
From field theory point of view,
this is a space time symmetry.
So in N equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory,
there's also global symmetry
we discussed before.
This is also global symmetry.
But this is global symmetry
associated with space time.
And there's also global
internal symmetry,
SO6 internal symmetry.
In N equals 4 super
Yang-Mills theory,
we discussed last time
there are six scalar fields.
You can rotate them each other.
And this can be considered
as coming from the D3 brane.
You can rotate six
transverse directions
the symmetry in rotating the
six transverse directions.
And on this side, there's
exactly the same symmetry.
So now this is isometry of S5.
So the isometry of S5
precisely gives you SO6.
So you have exactly
the same SO6.
And we will not be explicit.
You can also actually map the
supersymmetry between them.
You can also map the
So N equals 4 supersymmetry.
So there's a 4
supersymmetry, which
just comes from N equal to 4.
And because we have
conformal symmetry,
then the conformal
symmetry does not actually
commute with this
4 supersymmetry,
then generate another
4 supersymmetry.
And anyway, so essentially,
you have eight supercharge
of the [INAUDIBLE].
So this all together is
32 real superchargers.
So when we say N
equal to 4, so this
is N equal to 4 in terms of
four dimensional [INAUDIBLE].
So your supersymmetry has four
[INAUDIBLE] as the supercharge.
But the conformal symmetry
generates another 4.
So all together, you
have eight [INAUDIBLE],
four dimensional [INAUDIBLE],
as the supercharge.
For each [INAUDIBLE]
in four dimensions,
there are how many components?
How many components are
there for [INAUDIBLE]
in four dimensions?
AUDIENCE: Four.
HONG LIU: Four.
Because the two components,
but each component is complex.
And so there are
four real components.
So all together, you
have 32 real charges.
And similarly, you find--
I will not do this side.
You find the same
amount of supersymmetry.
But in this case, for
example, the low energy limit.
Let's just talk about the low
energy limit of this theory.
So the low energy limit,
as we said before,
just has to be super gravity.
So it has to be super gravity.
Then you find you actually
have exactly the same amount
of supersymmetry
in this geometry.
But the interesting thing
is that by definition,
the supersymmetry on the
gravity side is actually local.
So you actually
have the same amount
of local supersymmetries.
So if you look at
this correspondence
between each other, then
you actually see a pattern.
So now let me make some remarks.
So if you look at the
structure, this math in here,
you see a pattern.
On this side, all
these symmetries
are global symmetries.
But on this side,
all these symmetries
are local symmetries.
So this, I just said
that in super gravity,
the supersymmetry is local.
And the space time isometry
is just subset of a space time
coordinate transformation.
And space time
coordinate transformation
are local symmetries.
So the isometry is a
subgroup of diffeomorphism.
So diffeomorphism just means
the coordinate transformations.
And these are local symmetries.
Now we find the mapping is
on the field theory side,
the global symmetries is
mapped on the gravity side
into the local symmetries.
So for each global symmetry
in the field theory side,
there's a corresponding local
symmetry on the gravity side.
But you may immediately ask the
question, on the gravity side,
if you talk about
diffeomorphism,
then this is a huge
group-- certainly much,
much larger than what we are
talking about the isometry
here.
So why we are only
talking about isometry?
Why we don't talk about other
parts of the diffeomorphism,
only talk about isometry?
So what's special
about the isometry?
So the second
remark, why isometry?
Why only isometry?
Why only look at the isometry?
But let me just save time.
So the isometry is important
for the following reason.
Because even though this
is a subgroup-- so as
I mentioned last time, when
we talk about quantum gravity,
when we talk about string theory
and Anti-de Sitter times S5
in terms of AdS5 times S5,
you should keep in mind
that this AdS5 times S5 refers
to the asymptotic geometry.
Because as a quantum
theory, the theory
can fluctuate in the middle.
And the isometry can be
considered as a subgroup.
But the level is even though
the space time fluctuates,
but the AdS5 times S5 specifies
the asymptotic geometry
of the space time.
And the isometry is
precisely the subgroup
which leaves the asymptotic
form of the metric invariant.
So these are not
ordinary diffeomorphisms.
So the ordinary
diffeomorphisms--
so ordinary gauge
transformations,
let me just say more generally.
By gauge transformations,
also means the diffeomorphism
or just general gauge
transformations.
So when we talk about
gauge transformations, say
for example, in QED
or in QCD, et cetera,
we always assume-- so the
classical gauge transformation,
we can see that we always
take them to be fall off
sufficiently fast at infinity.
When we talk about
gauge transformations,
when we talk about the
typical diffeomorphisms,
these are the kind of
transformations we assume
goes to 1, say, at infinity.
And this isometry, which
leaves the asymptotic
over the metric invariant,
so these are essentially
the large gauge transformations.
So-called large
transformations is
that they don't go to
the Identity at infinity.
And of course, this is precisely
the large gauge transformations
which leaves the
asymptotic invariant.
So in a sense, these large
gauge transformations
can be considered as the global
part of the diffeomorphism.
So any questions on this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What does it mean
that those isometries are local?
What do you do with
isometry [INAUDIBLE]?
What do you mean when
you say that isometries--
HONG LIU: Yeah.
These are just coordinate
transformation.
A coordinate transformation is
always defined point by point,
right?
Just these are specific
coordinate transformations.
AUDIENCE: And what happens to
gauge symmetries [INAUDIBLE]?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: What happens
to gauge transformations
in the Yang-Mills part?
HONG LIU: No.
The gauge transformation
in the Yang-Mills part,
you don't see it.
Gauge freedom is just
redundant freedom.
You never see it
on the other side.
AUDIENCE: Does this list
exhaust all symmetries
of the Yang-Mills particle?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Exhausts all global symmetries
in the Yang-Mills theory part.
AUDIENCE: Not local?
HONG LIU: All the
global theories
on the Yang-Mills side,
and not local symmetries.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
discuss them, [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: There's a
u(n) gauge group there,
but they don't have
correspondence in the gravity
side.
The reason we don't consider
the gauge symmetry, because they
correspond to
redundancies and they
don't have to be present
on the other side.
You only need to do the physical
[INAUDIBLE] to be identical.
And this also is the reason
I make this remark here.
Even though all these
global symmetries,
they find the corresponding
local symmetries
on the gravity side.
But precisely due
to this remark,
those things which really
map to the global symmetries
in the field theory
can be considered
as a global part of the local
symmetries on the gravity side.
So even on the gravity
side, in some sense,
you should think of them
as global symmetries.
And they are large
gauge transformations.
Because the ordinary
gauge transformation
is just corresponding
to redundancy
of degrees of freedom.
And that should not be
reflected on the other side.
AUDIENCE: What do you mean by
large gauge transformation?
HONG LIU: Large
gauge transformation
means the gauge transformations
which don't vanish at infinity.
So the ordinary
gauge transformation,
just like in QED, in quantum
electrodynamics, when we talk
about gauge transformation.
The gauge transformations
we consider all the gauge
transformations which
go to zero at infinity.
And if you consider those
gauge transformations
which don't go to
zero at infinity,
and that's what we call
large gauge transformations.
And those large gauge
transformations essentially
is like the global part of
the u(1) gauge symmetry,
in some sense can
be considered as.
AUDIENCE: But that is the gauge
symmetry being gravity side.
HONG LIU: That's right.
So this is the part of the gauge
symmetry on the gravity side.
But the part corresponding
to the boundary
is the part associated
with the infinity.
AUDIENCE: Here in
isometry of AdS5,
we were showing,
like in p-set, it's
point to point local symmetry.
It's like just a
space time point.
But how about this conform
in this Yang-Mills theory?
What is the symmetry
of the object?
What kind of object does
this symmetry correspond
to because it seems--
HONG LIU: It's
conformal symmetry.
AUDIENCE: Conformal symmetry
of the component of the field?
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
It's the conformal symmetry
of the Minkowski space.
So on this side, you
have isometry of AdS.
On the other side, you
have conformal symmetry
of the Minkowski space.
So you're asking what are you
corresponding to on the field
theory side, right?
So that's mapped to
the conformal symmetry
of the Minkowski space.
AUDIENCE: So the
isometry is actually
large gauge transformations.
HONG LIU: Right.
So the story actually
is more general.
works more general.
This is the statement for the
N equal to 4 super Yang-Mills
theory.
So the story is more general.
So in the case which you
have, say, more general,
say duality between
a CFT in d dimensions
in Minkowski d with the AdS
d plus 1 dimensional gravity.
In any such duality, then
you always have the conformal
symmetry, which is SO(d, 2)
on this here mapped to AdS
isometry.
And any internal
gauge symmetry, say
if you have some u(s)
global symmetry here,
then this will be mapped
into a u(1) gauge symmetry.
Again, in the sense that
this u(s) global symmetry can
be considered as the global part
of this u(1) gauge symmetry,
the part which does
not vanish at infinity.
And it's always the case that
global supersymmetry here
would be corresponding to
the local supersymmetry here.
And also in exactly
the sense that
even for the local
supersymmetric transformation
in the gravity
side, there's also
a part which does not
vanish at infinity.
And that's the
part corresponding
to the global supersymmetry
on the field theory side.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What are the fermions
supersymmetry on the AdS side?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: In the low energy
limit on the AdS part,
what are the fermion
supersymmetry?
HONG LIU: It's the same thing.
What do you mean,
what about fermions?
So there will be some fermions.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] fermions?
So there is more than
gravitons on the AdS side
involved in low energy limits?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
There are gravitons, and
there are also some fermions.
There's something
called a [INAUDIBLE].
There are some other
fermions, et cetera.
AUDIENCE: Is it they who
carry the u(1) gauge charge?
HONG LIU: No.
Here is more general.
In this case, indeed--
so this isometry of S5,
once you deduce to AdS5, that
just again becomes a gauge
symmetry, SO(6) gauge symmetry.
And some fermions indeed are
charged on this SO(6) gauge
symmetry.
And here, it's
just more general.
So whatever things, anytime if
you have some global symmetry
here should be mapped to
some gauge symmetry here.
And we will say this a little
bit more a little bit later.
Do you have any other questions?
So now let's move to the
matching of parameters.
Again, this is
more like a review
of what we discussed before.
And again, first N equals to
4 super Yang-Mills theory.
And then this is type
IIB on AdS5 times S5.
So previously we said, from
the relation of the d-brane,
so the G Yang-Mills square
here is related to the 4 pi GS
here, string coupling.
And also, from the
d3-brane solution,
we find is that the
G Yang-Mills square--
we find, for example,
here the curvature radius
R has the following form, 4
pi GS and alpha prime squared.
So the N is the
same N on this side.
So the N is the gauge group N.
I should say the flux N. Anyway,
let me add something.
So the N is the number of
d-branes on this side which
translate into the flux.
So the flux N. And then
here is corresponding
to you have SU(N).
So this R, this
curvature radius is
related to the alpha prime
squared and the gs in this way.
And so on this side,
the dimension parameter
is given by R squared
divided by alpha prime.
So if you look at
this relation, if you
look at alpha prime 4
to alpha prime squared,
then you find this is
just relating the alpha.
From this relation,
4 pi GS is equal just
to G Yang-Mills square.
And the N is N.
This is the relation
between the parameters.
Any questions regarding this?
So on the gravity side, we said
these are the two parameters.
And of course, you
also have this N.
But these are the
two basic parameters.
And we can also,
instead of using GS,
as we said before, you can
also use the Newton constant.
So the 10 dimensional
Newton constant
is length dimension eight.
Then the dimensionless parameter
would be GN divided by R
to the power 8.
And the GN is related to
the GS and alpha prime
by this formula.
So now you can just use
the relation between the GS
to exactly translate this
into Yang-Mills coupling.
You just can use this
relation and then use
that to translate this into
the parameter in the Yang-Mills
theory side.
Then you find, once you
plug all those relations in,
how the GS and alpha prime,
et cetera related to N,
then you find here
actually, G Yang-Mills
have disappeared
in this relation.
What you find is that the
Newton constant essentially just
related to 1 over N squared.
Up to some parameter, just
So if you're expanding G Newton,
just like expanding 1 over N
squared.
So as we said before, we often
do dimensional reduction on S5.
Let me get a five
dimensional Newton constant.
So five dimensional
Newton constant
is equal to the 10
dimensional Newton constant.
And the difference
is the volume of S5.
We wrote this down before.
And the S5 is equal to pi
cubed R to the power fifth.
And then from here,
you can just work out.
So G5 has dimension 3.
Then G5 divided by R cubed,
again only related to N given
by pi divided by 2N squared.
So these relations are
often useful in the future.
So now let's look at [INAUDIBLE]
limits of this relation.
So let's first look at
the classical gravity
limit on the gravity side.
As we discussed at the beginning
of this class, by classic,
we always use h bar equal to 1.
So our h bar is
always equal to 1.
But quantum gravity is
captured by this parameter,
h bar times GN.
So even though h bar equal
to 1, in the limit when
GN goes to zero, then
you are in the regime
in which you can ignore
the quantum gravity effect.
So that's what we mean by
the classical gravity limit
is that this should go to
zero, and then alpha prime
should go to zero.
So this means the string
effect is not important.
And this is all
in the unit of R.
And here, when I
write these relations,
I have all set h bar equal to 1.
So when I say the
classical gravity limit,
which is this limit in
which h bar equal to 1,
but the effect of the Newton
constant goes to zero.
And the reason I emphasize it
is that if you have some matter
field in this geometry, then
those matter fields should
be treated as full quantum.
Just don't treat the
gravity as quantum,
but those matter fields
should be treated as quantum.
So the classical
gravity limit is
the same as QFT, Quantum Field
Theory in curved space time.
So gravity does not fluctuate.
So you have rigid
curved space time.
But your matter field can
fluctuate, h bar equal to 1.
So essentially, we are
dealing with quantum field
theory in curved space time.
So in the type
IIB super gravity,
there are many, many such
kind of matter fields,
and they all should be
treated quantum mechanically.
It's just that you should
consider this small.
So let's consider
what this means.
So GN small as a
dimensionless parameter,
this translates into
field theory side
if we use this relation.
So that means N
goes to infinity.
So this is the large N limit
of the Yang-Mills theory.
This is the large N limit
And then alpha
prime goes to zero.
From the relation between
the alpha prime and here,
when alpha prime goes to zero,
so this is in the downstairs.
Then that means this
should go to infinity.
So this is the t Hooft
coupling we defined before.
So this means the t Hooft
coupling goes to infinity.
So now we see a
remarkable relation.
So this is what we expect.
If you still remember what we
did before in the large N gauge
theory, in the large N gauge
theory in the large N limit,
the fluctuations become
very small, et cetera.
So this is consistent
that on the gravity side,
the fluctuation in the
geometry is very small.
And now, we see that the
decoupling of the string effect
requires on the field theory
side the strong coupling.
This is also something
roughly we said before.
Remember, when we talked
about large N gauge theory,
large N gauge theory,
you have planar diagram,
non-planar diagram, et cetera.
And at each level, say
at the planar diagram,
you need to sum over infinite
number of [INAUDIBLE] diagrams
which are all planar topology.
And if you look at just those
[INAUDIBLE] diagrams, of course
you don't see a space
time interpretation
because they are just
[INAUDIBLE] diagrams.
You don't see a
continuous surface.
And I already alluded before
that the continuous surface
can emerge if that
diagram becomes
sufficiently complicated.
And the way to make that
diagram sufficiently complicated
is to make it to be
a strong coupling.
The strong coupling,
then the diagram
with many, many
vertices will dominate.
And then the most dominated
diagrams are those diagrams
with not a lot of vertices.
And they essentially are
going to continue to limits.
And so this relation
[INAUDIBLE] realizes
that kind of intuition.
If you don't remember, go
back to your loads regarding
the large N gauge theory.
So this relation
is also remarkable
for the following reason.
Because this limit on the
gravity side is simple,
we can just deal
with quantum field
theory in the curved space
time, which we know how to do.
But on this side, it's
highly non-trivial
because this is an
infinite coupling limit.
So this will tell you that
the strong coupling limit is
described by classical gravity.
So that means that we can
actually use classical gravity
to, in principle, solve problems
which are strongly coupled.
So also, of course, there
are corrections beyond this.
So quantum gravity
corrections on this side,
so this is a classical
gravity limit
if you take those
parameters to go to zero.
But suppose those parameters
are not zero, just small.
Then you can just expand
in those parameters.
For example, can you
expand in GN divided by 8.
And that expansion essentially
gives you quantum gravity
corrections [INAUDIBLE].
And now, from this relation,
the expansion of GN
then is translated.
So this is expansion
in G Newton.
So from that
relation, we see this
has become the expansion 1 over
N squared in the field theory
side.
Just expansion 1 over N squared.
So on this side, you can
also take into account
that the alpha
prime is non-zero.
Then the alpha prime
corrections in the expansion
in alpha prime.
So from this relation,
translates in the expansion 1
over square root lambda.
So in principle, the
corrections beyond this limit
can again be studied
on the gravity side.
And then the 1 over square
root lambda corrections
then corresponding to
the string G corrections.
And the 1 over N squared
corrections corresponding
to the quantum
gravity corrections.
So this is the classical limit.
You also can see
the classical string
limit we considered before,
we discussed before.
In the classical
string limit, still you
can see the N go to infinity,
which corresponds to GN.
R8 goes to 0.
But here, the alpha
prime can be arbitrary.
And here the [INAUDIBLE]
coupling can be arbitrary.
So it can be finite.
So let me just say alpha
prime finite no longer zero.
And then this is just
corresponding to lambda finite,
which is no longer infinite.
So this is just a
standard t Hooft limit,
which we take N go to infinity
but keep lambda to be finite.
Standard t Hooft limit,
which we talked about before
in the large N gauge theory.
And then again, the
corrections in GN
will be corrections
in 1 over N squared.
So any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Doesn't small alpha
over R squared mean large GS?
HONG LIU: No.
That has nothing to do with GS.
These are two
independent parameters.
AUDIENCE: But expression
parentheses, so there's also N.
HONG LIU: This is--
AUDIENCE: So in the
classical [INAUDIBLE],
it means that since
lambda is finite,
so this means G Yang-Mills is 0.
HONG LIU: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: I mean lambda is
finite, so G Yang-Mills is 0
and it means weak coupling.
HONG LIU: No.
That's what we discussed before
in the large N gauge theory.
The effective
coupling is lambda.
Lambda is your effective
coupling in the large N limit.
AUDIENCE: When you draw
the diagram, [INAUDIBLE].
HONG LIU: Yeah.
So the lambda is your coupling.
The G Yang-Mills indeed,
in the t Hooft limit,
the G Yang-Mills will go to
0 when N goes to infinity.
But G Yang-Mills is
not the right parameter
to look at things.
Any other questions?
OK, good.
So now we can move on further.
We can talk about the matching
of the spectrum on two sides.
So from now on, I will just
restrict to essentially
the semi classical.
Here I should call semi
classical gravity limit
because we still treat the
matter fields essentially
as quantum.
So we call it semi
classical gravity limit.
So from now on,
so we will mostly
just consider the
semi classical gravity
regime in the gravity side.
Because essentially,
we know very little
about the string theory
in this geometry.
And also, I will
often use the phrase
which applies to the
general correspondence,
and not necessarily just N equal
to 4 super Yang-Mills theory
and the type IIB string theory.
I just use the language
assuming there's
a general correspondence between
some conformal field theory
and some AdS gravity theory.
So if the two theories
have to be the same,
two sides have to
be the same, then
you should be able to
map their spectrum.
So you should be able to
map their [INAUDIBLE] space,
for example.
So again, [INAUDIBLE] now
use the general language
of the boundary and
the [INAUDIBLE].
So the boundary theory
is a conformal theory
with this symmetry.
So for the moment, I don't
have [INAUDIBLE] symmetry.
So that means that [INAUDIBLE]
space should be organized
as the representations
of the conformal group,
say of this SO(d, 2).
And similarly here,
because here, the SO(d,
2) is the isometry group which
lives in infinite invariants.
And again, you should be able to
organize your [INAUDIBLE] space
using the representations
of the SO(d, 2).
And those representations, of
course, should be the same.
So if there's one
representation here,
then there must be a
[INAUDIBLE] representation here.
And if there's two [INAUDIBLE]
representations here,
there would be two identical
representations here.
The representations must match.
And on the boundary
side, the local operators
should also transform
on the representations
of the conformal symmetry.
And again, they conform
local operators can also
be mapped to, say, the
field on the gravity side.
So on the gravity side, the
fields should also transform
under this SO(d, 2) isometry.
That means that it
should be a one to one
correspondence between
the local operators here
and the bulk fields
on the gravity side.
There should be a one to one
correspondence on this side.
For example, in the boundary, if
there is some scalar operator,
there must be a
corresponding scalar
field on the gravity side.
Similarly, if there is some
vector operator in the boundary
theory, there must be a
corresponding bulk vector
field in the gravity side.
And similarly, if you have
some symmetric tensor,
then this must also be related
to some symmetric tensor.
So now I will often use the
notation that I've used.
Mu mu refers to the
boundary indices.
And the capital M, capital N
refers to the bulk indices.
Because they are on
different dimensions.
So then they are
not quite the same.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
HONG LIU: One second.
Let me just finish.
So here, I'm just talking
about the conformal symmetries.
And if the theory has
some other symmetries,
say some global symmetries or
supersymmetries, then again,
all those fields
and the state, they
should transform on
the representations
of those symmetries.
And again, they should
all match together.
They should all match together.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So we proved that the
super Yang-Mills theory really
lives on the
boundary of the AdS?
HONG LIU: No.
We did not prove that.
This is just a postulate.
First, let me just repeat again.
Yang-Mills theory lives
on Minkowski space.
And it's just an observation
that the Minkowski space
is the boundary of AdS.
And then you say you can imagine
that this is the boundary,
this relation is related to
the bulk and the boundary.
And this is a postulate
based on that fact.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I thought one of
the motivations for thinking
about the holographic
duality was to try
to escape [INAUDIBLE] theorem.
And all of a sudden,
it strikes me,
so we're trying to get
on the boundary spin
to massless particles.
Then they will also
exist in the bulk.
HONG LIU: Sorry.
In the field theory
side, there's
no massless spin to particles.
They map to some field in
the gravity side in the five
dimensions.
So this is some four
dimensional operator.
Then this maps to some
five dimensional fields.
AUDIENCE: I need to think
about my question better.
HONG LIU: Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if it's a
postulate that-- I mean,
it's not required that the
theory live on the boundary.
It seems that that's just sort
of a convenient way of thinking
about it.
But what implications would
it have if it actually
lived on the boundary?
Would it change anything?
HONG LIU: That's
what I said before.
So this discussion does
not depend on that.
This discussion does
You can say I don't need to
worry about that whether this
is on the boundary
or bulk, et cetera.
These are just some
different theories.
I want them to be the same.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK.
HONG LIU: But, as I said last
time, if you believe this bulk
and boundary relation,
then this is powerful
because then, you
can immediately
deduce that the Yang-Mills
theory on the S3 times time
then is related to the gravity
theory in the global AdS.
And that is a
nontrivial prediction
from thinking the boundary
and the bulk relation.
Now you can generalize it.
Because if I just
look at this relation,
I have no reason to suspect why.
You can argue from the
symmetry point of view also,
but that language
is more direct.
In principle, after
establishing the relation
between the Yang-Mills theory
in Minkowski space time
and this gravity in
the Poincare patch,
I may also, just based on
the group theory aspect,
to say that should generalize
to the Yang-Mills theory
on the S sphere
and the global AdS.
You may also be able
to do it that way.
But thinking from the
holographic point of view
will give you a direct
way to argue that,
give you an alternative
way to argue that.
Also, in your p-set, you have
checked this holographic bound.
And so that's a
confirmation of this.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So what does the
massless [INAUDIBLE] field
on the right map to if it's the
same representation of SO(d,
2)?
HONG LIU: Sorry.
Say it again.
AUDIENCE: So in the
representation line,
so if you have the massless
[INAUDIBLE] field on the right,
what does it map to on the left?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
We are going to talk about it.
So if there are
other symmetries,
then everything should match.
So now, as an
immediate check, you
can now just open
your old papers.
And if you load them--
because in the '80s,
people have worked out
the supergravity spectrum
precisely on this space.
So even though this relation
was discovered in '97, actually
in the '80s, people
already worked a lot
to consider this type to be
supergravity on this space.
Because this is a maximally
supersymmetric space,
et cetera.
Anyway, so people have
already spent lots of trouble
to actually work
out that spectrum.
And now you can just
open their paper.
Then there's a big table
about the different fields
and their representations,
et cetera.
And then you can immediately
see they actually
map to certain representation
of operators on the N equal to 4
super Yang-Mills theory.
Then you can
immediately check them.
Just based on the group
theory, check them.
So I won't go through
those details.
But let me just mention the most
important such kind of mapping
for these two theories.
And actually does
have consequences
for the general story.
So the most important mapping.
So as we said, on the
string theory side,
you always have this dilaton.
So these is some scalar field.
And this dilaton will appear
in the scalar field, in AdS5,
say, for example.
And it turns out
this dilaton field
is mapped to the Lagrangian
of the N equal to 4
super Yang-Mills theory.
So the Lagrangian
is a Lagrangian
of the N equals to 4
super Yang-Mills theory,
say, trace f squared plus
phi squared, et cetera.
So that's a local operator.
And it turns out that operator
is mapped to this dilaton.
And on the N equal to 4
super Yang-Mills theory side,
we have this SO6 gauge symmetry.
Did I just erase them?
We have this SO6 gauge symmetry.
Then we have the SO6
conserved current.
And it turns out this,
on the gravity side,
just maps to sO6 gauge field.
AUDIENCE: You said it was
an SO6 gauge symmetry?
HONG LIU: No.
In the N equal to 4, this
is a global symmetry.
But on this side, so this
appears as isometry on the S5.
But when you dimensionally
reduce on S5, then in AdS5,
then there will be
a pure gauge field
corresponding to each symmetry
generated [INAUDIBLE] S5.
And that naturally maps
to this conserved current
on the field theory side.
And then another universal
operator on the field theory
side is the stress tensor.
So no matter what
theory you consider,
you have stress tensor.
And this is mapped
to-- turns out,
to the metric perturbations.
It's a deviation
from the AdS metric.
Again, so at the representation
level, this is very natural.
So this is a symmetric tensor.
This is a symmetric tensor.
But physically, this
is also natural.
Physically, also natural.
I will elaborate this
a little bit further
from a different perspective
in a few minutes.
So do you have any
questions regarding this?
So now, given this
mapping, any operator
is due to a bulk field.
Then you can ask some
immediate questions.
For example, the quantum
numbers of these operators
will map to the quantum
numbers of the bulk fields.
And that's something I said
you can check their symmetries.
For example, not only
the representations
under this conformal
symmetry should
map under that representation.
And also, the
representation under that
SO6 we also match, et cetera.
So for local operator on
the field theory side,
so once we have this
mapping, we can immediately
ask questions related to
operators on this side,
and try to ask what's the
counterpart on the other side.
And ask the story about the
field on the gravity side,
and ask what's
happened on this side.
We can start developing
the relations.
So now let's start
discussing them.
So the first thing you can
do, so immediate question
you can ask is that
given the operator,
say operator O in
the field theory.
So there are some
natural questions
one can raise about
this operator.
For example, what is correlation
functions, et cetera?
And that we will
discuss a bit later.
But now let me discuss
another natural question.
And the natural thing to do is
to deform your original theory
by adding this operator
to the Lagrangian.
So I have an operator.
I can put the source.
I can put the coefficients.
And these coefficients
may depend or not
depend on the space
time coordinates.
And I can always add such
a term to a Lagrangian.
And then this deforms my theory
away from the original theory.
So this is a
natural thing to do.
And this phi 0 is often
called the source.
So this phi 0 is
So immediate question
you can ask--
and when phi 0 is
equal to constant,
then this corresponding to
a change in the coupling
for this operator.
So if your Lagrangian previously
already included this operator,
and then if you add such a term,
so phi 0 equal to constant,
then you are just changing the
coupling for that operator.
And if this operator
is not there,
then you just add
the new coupling.
But in general, you can make
it space time dependent.
AUDIENCE: Why is it
coupling since there's
no other operators
coupling without if we
say phi 0 is a constant?
HONG LIU: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: If phi
0 is a constant?
HONG LIU: No.
O is the operator.
It's the local operator.
AUDIENCE: Yes, but there
is no other operator
this operator O coupling with.
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
What is the meaning of operator?
The meaning of
operator is that O is
a sum of the product of fields.
And so there's already--
so this O may be phi cubed,
or may be phi 4, et cetera.
So example is O in the
scalar field theory.
If a scalar field theory
has a gauge field,
then I can write O
as trace F squared.
Then this corresponding
to changing the coupling
for trace F squared.
So immediate question is,
what does this operation-- so
in the field theory
point of view,
you can always do
this operation.
So the immediate question,
what does this corresponding
to in the bulk?
What does this operation
correspond to in the bulk?
So now I'll try to
answer this question.
As I said before, in
establishing such dictionary,
you often have to do lots of
guesswork, and then you check.
And the guesswork is based
on some very small clues.
So people who are able
to make good guesses
is that they are able to grasp
important clues sometimes
from very simple facts.
And so that is what's
good physicists do
is that they can see
non-ordinary things
from ordinary things.
So here, I will try to deduce
the answer to this question
by starting from this relation.
So let me start
with that relation.
Related to the GS.
Let's forget about p for pi.
And now, we've talked about
before GS string coupling can
be considered as the expectation
value of the dilaton field.
Let me actually
call it capital Phi.
So we mentioned before when
we talked about string theory
that this string coupling can
be considered as expectation
value of the dilaton field.
Of course in general,
again, the dilaton
can fluctuate, et cetera.
So normally, in
flat space, when we
say the dilaton has expectation
value, what we normally
say is that the value of
the dilaton at infinity
because the boundary by
infinity, that's how you fix.
And similarly, for space time
like AdS with a boundary,
and the expectation
value of this dilaton
can be identified with
the value of the dilaton
at the boundary of AdS.
So here, I write partial AdS
means the boundary of AdS.
So this is the value of AdS,
value of phi at the boundary.
So expectation value
essentially can
be associated with the
boundary value of the field.
AUDIENCE: You mean
if it is a constant?
You mean if expectation
value of the phi is constant?
Or if it's, function-wise,
equal to the boundary limit?
HONG LIU: No, no, no.
Think about the following thing.
As I said, phi in
principle can fluctuate.
And its expectation may also be
able to fluctuate in the space
time.
But the only sensible way to
talk about expectation value
is to talk about its
value at the boundary
because we assume the boundary
conditions don't fluctuate.
It's the same thing
for flat space.
And we always specify
the boundary condition
at the spatial
infinity, for example.
And in the AdS, which is also
space time with a boundary,
than we can associate
the constant parts
of the expectation value as
the value at the boundary.
Now you have to use a little
bit stretch of imagination.
The following fact,
you don't need to.
So now, with this relation, we
have established a connection
between the Yang-Mills theory
coupling with the value of phi
at the boundary of AdS.
And now remember, this
Yang-Mills coupling,
so I will not be careful about
1 over Yang-Mills squared.
This is related.
This is the coupling or source
for the Lagrangian of N equals
to 4 super Yang-Mills theory.
So now we can deduce
here two things.
In particular, if we
deform the Lagrangian,
say, change this coupling,
deform the boundary
by changing the coupling,
which corresponds
to you add some delta G,
say the Lagrangian of N
equal to 4 super Yang-Mills,
deform the boundary
set by changing the coupling.
And this corresponding
to you essentially
change the boundary
value of dilaton
because these are related.
So now, this example gives us
the answer to this question.
This example gives
us this question.
From here, we can deduce first
that the operator corresponding
to the dilaton must be the N
equal to 4 super Yang-Mills
Lagrangian, as you can already
deduce from some other methods,
say using group
theory, et cetera.
And the second is that phi
0 O, in the boundary theory,
adding a phi 0 O in
the boundary theory
must be related-- now I'm
generalizing this story.
The bulk field phi-- so
now I'm no longer not
necessarily using the dilaton.
The bulk field phi due to O
has a boundary value phi 0.
Any questions about this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Your
choice of operator O
should be consistent with
all symmetries, right?
HONG LIU: Hm?
AUDIENCE: You're
not pre-choosing O?
HONG LIU: No.
O can be anything.
AUDIENCE: Consistent with
original symmetries of the--
HONG LIU: No, it
doesn't have to be.
You can deform the
theory without-- you
can break the symmetry.
That deformation can
break the symmetry.
If you want to
preserve the symmetry
of the original Lagrangian,
then you can choose a certain O.
But in principle, you
can choose any O. You can
break the symmetry if you want.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
to always then break
some symmetry on the AdS part?
HONG LIU: Yeah.
Impose this kind of
boundary conditions.
Then you may break
AdS symmetry too.
So now we have
answered this question.
And then of course, this
just provides the answer.
Then you would check it.
And we will check it
later using other methods.
Now I'm saying because I
already know it's true.
But in real life, what you
will do from this example,
you will say, ah,
this must be the case.
Then you will start trying
to find examples to check it.
Start to find other
ways to check it.
And we will describe it later.
So in the end, what
we will describe
is a self consistent story.
I will not contradict myself
in my later discussion.
So if we assume this, I
can also use this to argue.
I can also use
this identification
to argue this too.
So let me call this
star and star star.
I can use this identification
to make star and star star
natural for any
duality, not only N
equals 4 super Yang-Mills theory
and this type IIB gravity.
It's that any conserved
curve in the boundary theory
must be equal to some gauge
field in the gravity side,
and the stress tensor should
always be due to the metric.
So now I'm going to
use this argument
to make that a little
bit more natural.
So let's first consider this.
So suppose I have a conserved
current, J, J. I have a J mu.
For simplicity, let me
just take it to be u(1).
Then I can deform
the boundary theory
by adding a source for this J mu
by adding a boundary Lagrangian
term like this.
And a mu is the source.
And then according to
this identification,
the A mu must be A mu-- we
should be able to identify it
as the boundary value of some
bulk field, A mu evaluated
at z equal to 0.
So this is a bulk vector field.
So if this is true, there
must exist a vector field
due to this vector field.
And this must correspond to
the boundary value of that.
But now we can argue why
this should be a gauge field.
So now I want to argue
this is a gauge field.
And to see this is very
easy because since J mu is
conserved, then this
coupling-- so let
me call this star star star.
Let me call it star star star.
So since this is conserved,
and this star star star
is invariant under the
following transformation,
A mu goes to A mu plus partial
mu lambda x for any lambda x.
So that means the A mu, this
A is the boundary value of A.
So that means this
capital A, that
means the dynamics of this A
mu should also be invariant.
If I change the boundary value
of A by this transformation,
the dynamics of A mu
should also not change.
Let me call it AM so the bulk
and general will be different.
But this is like a
gauge transformation.
So this is like a
So we deduce that
somehow, this must
be some subset of the
bulk gauge transformation.
Now call it star to the power 4.
Then star to the
power 4 also must
be a subset of some bulk
gauge transformation.
So this does not prove it,
but makes it more natural.
This argument makes
it more natural.
The fact that the
boundary value of A
has such kind of gauge symmetry.
So in some sense,
this must generalize
to some gauge symmetry
in the full gravity side.
So similarly, you can do this
for the metric for the stress
tensor.
Similarly, you can do this
for the stress tensor.
So for the stress tensor,
so for the star star, again,
we can add h mu mu x T mu mu
to the boundary Lagrangian.
And this is the source
to the stress tensor.
And now, from your knowledge
of quantum field theory,
when I add such a term to the
field theory, it's the same.
So this is equivalent to I
deform the boundary space
time metric from just eta mu
mu to eta mu mu plus h mu mu.
So let me call this
quantity g mu mu b.
So adding such a term
source for the stress tensor
is like you deform your
space time geometry
a little bit by this source.
This is when h is very small.
When we consider
the information,
we always consider
the source is small.
But now, we can argue this
thing, mass corresponding
to the boundary
value of the metric
in the gravity side for
the following reason.
So if you look at
this expression,
so if you look at
even the pure AdS
metric before you
do any deformation,
so this is just due to
the original theory.
So from the AdS metric, so
the original AdS metric,
the g mu mu component.
So let me write this
AdS metric in the form,
say, R squared, z
squared, separate
the z squared with the rest.
So this is essentially the
component of the bulk metric
along the boundary direction.
The boundary value of this
metric component evaluates
z equal to 0 is
equal to R squared
divided by z squared eta mu mu.
So that just comes from the
AdS metric, just this g mu mu.
And when you go the
boundary, just given by this.
And this is eta mu mu.
We recognize it just
as the boundary metric.
So these correspond to deform.
Since adding this
term corresponds
to deform the boundary
metric, so we expect,
when we add this term,
so this corresponding
to deform the g mu mu
now to the 0 become.
So we expect this becomes
equal to g mu mu b.
So this tells you
that the stress tensor
must be due to the metric
perturbations in the gravity
side.
The stress tensor
must be corresponding
to the metric perturbation
on the gravity side
because it's corresponding
to perturb the boundary
conditions of the bulk
metric-- corresponding
to preserve the boundary
condition for the bulk metric.
So this is a very
general statement
valid for any correspondence
between the gravity
and the field theory.
And that also tells you that
if you have a theory which
due into a higher dimensional
theory, and then that theory,
if the field theory
has a stress tensor,
then this bulk theory
must have gravity
because this bulk theory
must have a dynamical metric.
And if you have a dynamical
metric, then you have gravity.
So you can say, if
any field theory
is due to a theory of one higher
dimension, that theory of one
higher dimension must involve
gravity-- nothing about quantum
gravity.
Let's stop here.